one of the more bizarre discoveries ever
found at the pyramids of egypt is
something that surprisingly few people
are even aware of
did you know that the oldest largest and
best preserved boat ever discovered from
ancient egypt was found buried just
steps away from the great pyramid of
giza
that's right and perhaps the only thing
stranger than finding ancient boats
hidden at one of the more unlikely
places imaginable is the explanation for
where this boat came from and why it's
there which only further adds to the
mysteries of ancient egypt itself
and what you're seeing here is referred
to as the khufu ship named after the
pharaoh who is alleged to have ordered
the construction of the great pyramid
and due to its extraordinarily close
proximity to the great pyramid it was
concluded that it must surely have been
among this pharaoh's fleet of ships and
possibly even khufu's own personal
vessel as it was placed into a pit and
sealed like a tomb with large stones
that spanned the entire length of this
140 foot or 43 meter long boat which
then lay hidden for 4
600 years until it was discovered in an
excavation in 1954
but this is the part where things get
weird because the fact that it is the
oldest largest and best preserved boat
ever discovered from ancient egypt has
some very interesting and profound
implications i mean besides the fact
that it has long been suggested that the
egyptians would surely have transported
the countless massively heavy stone
blocks down the nile river on boats as
of course doing so over land and
especially in the vast distances
spanning as far as several hundred miles
over hills and various terrain would be
more than impractical and perhaps not
even possible
and this brings us to the question of
where are these alleged boats that would
have moved stones as heavy as one
thousand tons such as at the ramesseum
which was moved nearly 150 miles
or even as heavy as the 1100 stone
statue that was somehow transported more
than 600 miles or a thousand kilometers
to tannis egypt prior to this statue's
mysterious destruction now hold that
thought as i'll come back to that
important detail in a moment and let me
first ask you a question which is do you
really think that whoever it was that
designed and constructed one of the
largest and most precise structures ever
built in the history of mankind which
even today is shrouded in so much
mystery as we still do not know with any
certainty as to how it was constructed
all we truly have are theories and
guesswork as to how the ancients could
have accomplished such a spectacular and
animated marvel of engineering
yet this shoddy looking boat has been
suggested to be the personal craft of
transportation for the royal pharaoh who
supposedly ordered this to be built
it just seems to me that whoever would
have had the means knowledge and
technical capability to orchestrate the
great pyramids construction would surely
have had a personal vessel more
sophisticated than this because
it's curious to consider that if you
could make this happen
then is this realistically the best you
could do for yourself i mean come on it
doesn't even have windows
and let's be honest and i mean no
disrespect but i have to say that this
rowboat
is a total piece of crap in comparison
to the mathematical and technological
precision of the pyramids of giza in
fact it's almost silly to even make such
a brazen comparison yet this assumption
is what we've been told to believe
and i must say that is also a bit
intriguing that so few people are even
aware of this boat's existence i mean
it's not some secret but the reality is
that many people are totally surprised
to hear that several boats not just this
one were found just steps away from the
giza pyramids in fact you can read
articles about them from harvard and
other scholarly journals which reminds
me that i should point out another
lesser-known detail which is that the
nile river was once eight miles closer
to the gisa plateau putting it nearly
right up to the pyramids themselves
this whole area which is now city was
once the bottom of the nile river and
the cliff-like formation that makes up
the plateau was the river's shoreline
pretty interesting as it further paints
us a picture of just how much this area
has changed from what it was thousands
of years ago when the ancient empire was
thriving
but that said it seems to me that this
boat is nothing more than a shipping
vessel as it almost looks exactly the
same as other examples i saw depicted
while touring egypt clearly meant to
transport goods and various supplies and
when you compare the two it's rather
evident so i'm not so sure that it's
even remotely appropriate to label it
the khufu ship but that aside this
brings me back to the important detail
which is the fact that this is the
largest ancient egyptian boat ever found
yet consider its narrow beam in just how
shallow its hull is clearly this could
not possibly carry stone blocks of any
substantial size or weight it would
undoubtedly capsize and to be fair the
experts do not claim that this
particular style of boat would have been
used for transporting stones
so the question for me becomes where are
all the alleged boats that could have
carried millions of stone blocks up the
nile river especially the large stones
including the hundreds of 70 plus ton
granite blocks that make up the internal
structure of the pyramid including the
so-called kings chamber and not to
mention the 1 000 ton stone statues
found elsewhere that i mentioned earlier
the reality is that the only thing we
have are theorized animations that were
created in modern times which although i
applaud the development of these
theories make no mistake the egyptians
did not depict this in hieroglyphs and
not only that these theorized animations
have never actually been tested in real
life
think about that
so it becomes quite bizarre when you
realize that we've never found one
single boat or even one single depiction
of a boat that could support and
transport large stones for the egyptians
we've certainly found an abundance of
examples showing egyptians transporting
light cargo but where are the depictions
of them carrying millions of massive
stone blocks
because it's one thing to provide
sketches and theorized animations in
modern times but where are the ancient
hieroglyphs you see this is what i've
been saying for so long on this channel
which is that the more you research the
topic of lost ancient civilizations in
the ancient egyptians you see how many
profound unanswered questions there
actually are and between a complete lack
of hieroglyphs showing anything about
how the egyptians could have cut and
carved granite
it becomes quite apparent for all who
have eyes to see that the mysteries
involving the ancient egyptians is quite
real now i will be discussing more about
this topic in future videos but right
now i have a few important things to say
first of all
go check out my recent podcast with
danica patrick it's on her channel and
if you're not familiar she's a legendary
racing star first woman ever to win an
indie race and also competed in nascar
and i remember seeing her on joe rogan a
few years ago and being blown away by
how dynamic her interests were turns out
she's a huge fan of ancient
civilizations and has traveled to egypt
as well
so we chatted for a few hours on her
podcast and go check this out we talk
everything from
lost ancient civilizations atlantis
conspiracies aliens
consciousness
manifestation law of attraction and many
other fascinating things and i think
that you'll find this conversation quite
enjoyable and i also discussed my iraq
war experience for the first time many
people have asked me to dive into that
in a video and this is the first time
i've spoken about it publicly
definitely go check out that podcast
there's a link in the description and my
pinned comment and subscribe to her
channel
i've got to know her a bit and she is
one of the most interesting down to
earth kind people i've met and had an
opportunity to chat with and i know you
won't be disappointed
but there are other things to share now
too which is
i am now creating a rumble and an
odyssey account alternative tech is now
a must for obvious reasons
censorship is real and those platforms
are not about that life they do not
shadow ban so i will have the
opportunity to say things that i've been
biting my tongue on for far too long
many of you who have been following me
since the beginning saw how many how
diverse my topics were whether it was
from various conspiracies talking about
you know epstein's plane and bill
clinton jfk
animal rights
spirituality and many other things but
the world we live in today has gone
quite crazy in fact it's upside down
i am fully aware
of things that are happening in this
world and i've been biting my tongue out
of fear
fear of what would happen to something
that i spent so much time and effort
building and take pride in things that i
that i believe if i spoke my mind they
would
this channel which is incredibly
distracting and upsetting so that said i
owe it to everyone to speak my mind
because it's come to the point now where
to say nothing
about the direction where things are
heading for the future of this world is
to almost be complicit
so follow me on rumble and odyssey and
i'm going to start speaking up far more
and also as you may have noticed i've
never promoted my patreon i haven't done
much with it but now's the time to step
it up and give back to those who have
supported me and give an incentive for
you to support me on patreon which is
moving forward after this video
all future uploads will be posted to
patreon a day earlier this will give you
a chance to see it first leave a comment
i'll have more of a chance of getting
traction
and in the comments and i think it'll
just be a fun thing to do and i'll get
to the point where i'll start sharing
things on there that i won't share
elsewhere but that said i'm of course
sharing everything on youtube and rumble
and odyssey so i'm not leaving youtube i
love youtube guys
but like when you get so many comments
from people saying that hey i'm
subscribed i have the bell clicked and i
still i still don't get notified
that's a problem
so all of that said what else do i got
here um i have a few awesome videos in
the works this one's a bit short um i
want to to knock something out i've been
working on a few other things
wait till you see my best videos are yet
to come
um so i couldn't be more excited the
future is absolutely bright um but yeah
check me out on rumble odyssey go check
out danica patcher
the podcast we did together follow her
and stay tuned for many more awesome
videos to come i'm jimmy corsetti my
channel is called bright insight hit the
like button subscribe and leave a
comment on all of this and just to be
clear
i'm not suggesting for a second that
that koofu boat would have been used for
carrying stones i already addressed that
but guys do you really think
that that's the same
mode of transportation that whoever it
was that could have designed and
orchestrated the construction the great
pyramid went thieves had something a
little bit better so if nothing else it
seems to me that it is vastly
inappropriate to call it the khufu ship
but anyways i've already said all this
i'll close it up there take care
everybody